[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
بعد زيارته الى
عكس تيار واشنطن وينصح اوروبا بعدم
الاعتماد عليها وعلى دولاررها
ردا على زياره رئيس التايوان لكاليفورنيا
الصين تبث محاكاه لشن هجوم على تايوان
واستعادتها
من استغلال صور محاكمته الى هجوم عكسيه
على الديمقراطيين ترامب يعود من جديد
بسلسله تصريحات تمهيدا لترشيحه
تكشف عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن
متمسكه بعلاقتها الاستراتيجيه مع السعوديه
وسيكون لدينا ايضا
[موسيقى]
العوده يدخل البيوت السودانيه من الشاشه
الصغيره ناصر القصبي يبدع في اتقان
العاميه السودانيه ويحقق نسب مشاهدات
عاليه
[موسيقى]
من على متن طائره العوده من الصين قرر
الرئيس الفرنسي ان يحلق عكس الرياح
الامريكيه والاوروبيه ليخرج بتصريحات
مفادها على اوروبا الا تصبح اوروبا تابعه
للولايات المتحده انهى مكرون زياره
استغرقت ثلاثه ايام ليخرج بهذه النصيحه ان
على اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها بالولايات
المتحده وان تتجنب مواجهه محتمله مع الصين
بشان تايوان ماكرون قال ان الخطر الكبير
الذي قد تواجهه اوروبا هو الوقوع في ازمات
ليست ازماتها مؤكدا انه ليس من مصلحه
اوروبا تسريع ازمه تايوان وبناء موقفها
بالتبعيه للولايات المتحده او بتلميحات من
الصين معتبرا انه في حال اشتدت التوترات
بين هاتين القوتين فلن يكون لاوروبا الوقت
ولا الموارد
لتمويل استقلالها الاستراتيجي واضاف
ماكرون ان على اوروبا تقليل اعتمادها على
الدولار الامريكي خارج الحدود الاقليميه
تصريحات اطلقها الرئيس الفرنسي اثناء
زيارته للصين عن دور بكين الايجابي في حل
الازمه الاوكرانيه فسرت حينها بالمجاملات
السياسيه لكن ان يتبنى ماكرون خطابا حادا
ضد واشنطن والدولار بعد الزياره يحمل
موقفا فرنسيا يتماشى مع داوتي بكين بضروره
استقلاليه اوروبا هو ما لم يكن استكمالا
للمجامله
نهج اوروبي جديد حملته تصريحات ماكرون
لمجله
حملت نبره حاده تجاه واشنطن قد تشحد ازمه
جديده بين الطرفين والتي لن تكون الاولى
خاصه بعد الازمه الدبلوماسيه الناجمه عن
صفقه الغواصات بين باريس وكامبيرا
مكرون عاد من الصين بنبره جديده داعيا
اوروبا الا تنجر وراء ازمات ليست ازماتها
ما قد يكون خطرا كبيرا عليها مشيرا الى
التصعيد الحاصل بين الصين والولايات
المتحده اثر ازمه تايوان
سياسه النائي بباريس عن التبعيه للولايات
المتحده وصفت نيويورك تايمز بورقه دوجول
الجنرال والرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق الذي
لطالما اتبع تلك السياسه
ليس من مصلحه اوروبا تسريع ازمه تايوان
وبناء موقفها بالتبعيه لموقف الولايات
المتحده او بتلميحات من الصين
الرئيس الفرنسي اكد على ضروره تعزيز
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاوروبيه وتقليل
الاعتماد على واشنطن خاصه في مجال الامن
هندسه امنيه اوروبيه جديده ظهرت في معرض
حديث ماكرون متوافقه مع ما تدعو اليه
الصين من قبل وتتحد الشراكه والتحالف
الاوروبيه الامريكيه الامني
المتمثله في حلف النيتو
اوروبا يجب ان لا تعتمد على النيتو اوروبا
بحاجه الى اكتساب المزيد من الاستقلاليه
في التقنيه والقدرات الدفاعيه بمنع عن
الولايات المتحده
زياره اثار التساؤلات حول موقف ماكرون
تجاه الصين هل هي نوع من الحمايه لاوروبا
من اثار الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ام
توجه جديد لمستقبل اوروبي دون تبعيه
للولايات المتحده اذا عمر العربيه
معنى من باريس وليد عباس الكاتب الصحفي
اهلا بك معنا استاذ وليد كيف على المشاهد
ان يفهم هذه التصريحات
المكرونيه اذا صح التعبير اذا كنت توافق
عليها هل هي تصريحات مكرونيه ان تصريحات
مؤسسات فرنسيه
هي تصريحات مكرونيه بالدرجه الاولى ولكن
يجب ان لا نفاجئ بهذا الموقف يجب ان نعود
لنتذكر مواقف الرئيس الفرنسي منذ فتره
رئاسته الاولى هو دعا منذ البدايه الى ان
تكوين دفاع اوروبي وضروره ان يكون
الاوروبا استراتيجيه خاصه بها وان تتحول
الى قوه على مستوى القوه الاخرى في العالم
صحيح خصوصا بعد انتقل العالم الى عالم
متعدد الاقطاب وهو من قال ان حلف الاطلسي
في حاله موت دماغي اذا هذه سياسه قديمه
يصر عليها الرئيس ماكرون منذ البدايه وهي
استراتيجيه خاصه بان تكون تتحول اوروبا
الى قوه مستقله قادره على الدفاع عن نفسها
وان تكون في المستوى الاقتصادي تحمل ثقه
الاقتصادي يعادل القوه الاخرى ونحن حاليا
في مرحله تغييرات جذريه على المستوى
العالمي مع صعود الصين مع صحيح تراجع
الولايات المتحده بعض وهنا اهميه ربما
استاذ وليد
كانه هذا النوع من الخطاب التصعيدي ضد
الولايات المتحده ليس ضدها تماما ولكن ضد
التبعيه بين قوسين كانه هدا هذا الخطاب في
فتره من الفترات مكرونيا وعاد الان
ليتصاعد مع هذا الدخول القوي للصين على
الساحه الدوليه ومع كل الازمات الدوليه
المعروفه اذا من هنا توقيت مهم جدا ولكن
هل هو قادر حقيقه على فعل شيء ملموس في
هذا الصدد ام انه هذه التصريحات ستبقى
تصريحات على ورق
ما يريد ان يفعله صعب للغايه هناك عوائق
عديده للغير ولكن ماكرون الفرق الوحيد
وكنت اريد ان اقول هو اللهجه هو اللهجه
الحاده التي استخدمها هذه المره
مكروه حاول بالفعل فيما يتعلق بالسياسه
الدفاعيه المشتركه ولكن المانيا خيبت امله
في المره الاولى يبدو ان المانيا الان
تعود بعض الشيء الى وجهه النظر الفرنسيه
من حيث ضروره بناء دفاع ما اوروبي ولكن
ليس كما يراه ماكرون دفاع حقيقي يعني
تستبدل به تستبدل اوروبا به الاطلسي ايضا
هناك مشاكل كثيره على مستوى الدول 29 لا
نستطيع القول ان كافه اعضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي قد يتفقون على السياسه من هذا
النوع خصوصا دول اوروبا الشرقيه التي
ترتبط ربما اكثر بالولايات المتحده منها
باوروبا بالتالي هناك من يتحدث اليوم في
فرنسا من بين المتابعين والمحللين عن
ضروره ان يكون داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك
ثقل الاساسي مما لا شك تشكله فرنسا
والمانيا وربما دول اخرى مجاوره تتمتع
بنفس الرؤيا الاوروبيه لضروره وجود اوروبا
كقوه ثالثه على الساحه العالميه
ذكرت حضرتك في معرض اجابتك على السؤال
الثاني المانيا
يعني ذات الثقل الاساسي مع باريس في
الاتحاد كعينادين اساسيين للاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن اي اوروبا ينادي عليها
ماكرون اذا استثنينا المانيا بريطانيا
خارجه من الاتحاد الاوروبي دول اخرى اما
ضعيفه اما منقسمه على نفسها اما يعني الى
اي مدى فعلا قلت لي قبل قليل انه صعب جدا
ما يقوله هو يقول لماذا علينا اتباع
الايقاع الذي يختاره الاخرون يعني الهجوم
كله على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعتقد ان هذه التصريحات تحدي اولا هو من
الممكن ان يدعوا اوروبا الغربيه عموما يجب
ان لا ننتبه الا ننسى انه بالرغم من ضعف
بعض هذه الدول مثل ايطاليا اليونان او
اسبانيا الا ان المجموعه الجسم الاوروبي
الغربي
الكتله الصلبه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي تشكل
مع بعضها في حاله اتحاد تشكل ثقل كبير على
المستوى الاقتصادي وعلى المستوى السياسي
على ساحه الدوليه ولكن اعتقد ان التصريحات
ماكرون اليوم كانت نوعا من الدفاع اكثر
منها من الهجوم نوع من محاوله الحد من
الخسائر اكثر منها دعوه الى القيام بشيء
محدد اوروبا اليوم ترى انها في هذه الحرب
الاوكرانيه هي الخاسر الاساسي بمعنى ليس
فقط على المستوى الاقتصادي والمالي لانها
تقدم الكثير في هذه الحرب تريد ان تقول عن
طريق امام المزيد من التنازلات المزيد من
التبعيه
بالتاكيد هو يقول نحن نعيش حاليا مراره
تجربه الحرب الاوكرانيه وندفع الثمن غاليا
سياسيا واقتصاديا وبالتالي لا يجب ان
نندفع في هذا الطريق ليس من مصلحه اوروبا
بالتاكيد تصعيد سريع مع الصين في هذه
اللحظه فيما يتعلق بتايوان ربما يرى
ماكرون ان الولايات المتحده تصاعد بصوره
سريعه مع الصين في هذا المجال وان هذا امر
يعني غير مفيد لاوروبا غير مجدي لاوروبا
يجب ان نشير الى انه عم بحذر كمان من
الصين
لانه عم بحذر ايضا من تسارع الاحتكار
الثنائي الصيني الامريكي داعيا الى
استغلال هذه السنوات المتبقيه لاستقلال
اوروبا استراتيجيا فقط للاشاره للمشاهدين
استاذ وليد عباس الكاتب الصحفي
اعذرني اعذرني للاكتفاء بهذا القدر نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا
تحياتي اليك لنا لقاءات اخرى ان شاء الله
تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
في مضيق تايوان حيث تتصاعد التوترات بشكل
تدريجي ما ينظر بامكانيه حدوث مواجهه في
اي وقت فالصين ماضيه في مناورات عسكريه
حول جزيره تايوان ردا على زياره رئيس
التايوان للولايات المتحده وعلى لقائها
مسؤولين امريكيين فاين بالتحديد التدريبات
الصينيه وما حجمها بحسب مصدر امني تايواني
فان التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول قناه باشي
التي تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين التدريبات
الصينيه تضمنت محاكاه لضربات دقيقه على
اهداف رئيسه في تايوان ولتطويق الجزيره
بالكامل وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول
انها رصدت مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات
سوء 30 وقذفات h6 الى جانب احدى عشره
سفينه حربيه اخرى في محيط الجزيره من
جانبها قالت رويترز نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه
ان المواجهه باتت وشيكا حيث تتواجد عشر
سفن صينيه اضافه الى مثلها تايوانيه على
خط المواجهه بالقرب من الخط الاوسط
للجزيره طيب اكدت انها لن تسهم في التصعيد
لكنها توعدت بالرد بالشكل الملائم على
تدريبات بكين واشنطن حليف التايوان من
جانبها قالت انها تراقب المناورات الصينيه
عن كثب مؤكده انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد
وقدرات لضمان السلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه
التوتر الامني الى جانب السياسي خيم على
مضيق تايوان في ظل المناورات التي تنفذها
الصين لليوم الثاني على التوالي ما ينذر
بامكانيه حدوث المواجهه في اي وقت
[موسيقى]
ان الخط الاوسط للجزيره
طيب في اكدت انها لن تسهم في التصعيد
لكنها تواعدت بالرد بالشكل الملائم على
تدريبات بكين
في حين قالت واشنطن حليفه انها تراقب
المناورات الصينيه عن كتب مؤكده انها
تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات لضمان
السلام والاستقرار بالمنطقه
السنه الجمهوريه قال ان الولايات المتحده
يجب ان تنشر صواريخ كروز نوويه تطلق من
البحر في المحيط الهادئ لردع الصين واضاف
جراهم انه منفتح على ارسال قوه امريكيه
الى تايوان للدفاع عن الجزيره قائلا ان
الغموض الاستراتيجي لا يجدي نفعا وفق
تعبئه
الجانب الاقتصادي من هذا الموضوع كله الان
على العالم والعالم العربي تحديدا من
اثينا عبر سكايب معنا الدكتور عبد اللطيف
درويش استاذ الاقتصاد واداره الازمات
بجامعه كارديف اهلا بك معنا دكتور نريد ان
نرصد معك ابرز مكامل القلق وعلى اي صعد
فيما يتعلق بتاثير هذا التصعيد ليس ان
اشتعلت حرب وانما الان التصعيد في الهند
والهادئ اقتصاديا على العالم كيف يمكن ان
يؤثر وبالتالي على عالمنا العربي
يعني اولا هو تقطيع
لسلاسل الامداد اقل قلق بالسوق
القلق واسوا شيء ما يسمى
شيء على عمليه الاستهلاك وهي روح عمليه
الاستهلاك يروح النظام الراسمالي اسوا ما
في الازمه التي نعيشها ليست كازمه كورونا
بكل مساوئها وانما ان الطبيعه الغربيه
التي اذا
مسيت مس احد الاقتصاد الغربي او الرفاه
الغربي فالغرب للطبيعه الغربيه لا تتردد
الشخصيه الغربيه عن استعمال كل الوسائل
اسلحه نوويه اسلحه استراتيجيه للحفاظ على
موقع واعتقد ان الغرب بما فيه تحدث عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكل الدول
المعسكر الغربي خاسر السوق الى الابد
لصالح الصين صالح العديد من الدول
الاسيويه والدول الاخرى الاسواق العالميه
ولن يستطيعوا استعادتها نتيجه افتقارهم
الميزه التنافسيه امام الصين واندونيسي
وماليزا وهذه الدول فبالتالي ايضا خروج
العديد من الدول عن التنسيق الغربي في
موضوع تحديد اسعار الطاقه كالابك والتي
كانت بقياده السعوديه وايضا الامارات خروج
ايضا عن النظام الغربي الذي يتحكم
بالاقتصاد والسياسه العالميه للسنوات اسوا
ما فيها الازمه كما اسلفت انهم لن يترددوا
عن استعمال كل الوسائل
لاعاقه الصين واعاقه الدول الاخرى واعاقه
روسيا
بموضوع المعسكر الغربي انت تعتبر انه هذا
تم انتهى او انه في في طور الانتهاء يعني
خساره المعسكر الغربي
للمعركه اقتصاديا امام الصين
والمعسكر اللي حليف لالها او يصير في
فلكها خسر تلك المعركه تماما باعتقادك
وبتنا امام تاريخ اقتصادي جديد يكتب في
العالم
نعم وانا استشهد بمقوله للرئيس بايدن لم
يقل بايدن ان الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
والنوويه الصينيه خطر قال ازدهار الصين هو
تحديد لامننا وتهديد لنا فبالتالي
الازدهار لا تستعمل الا للمجانب الاقتصادي
نعم هو خسر الاسواق الذي يعرف افريقيا
ويذهب الى افريقيا ودول امريكا اللاتينيه
والدول الاسيويه يعرف كم هي الاستثمارات
الصينيه والدوري الصيني كبير جدا حتى ان
بعض الدول الافريقيه سيستعمل العمله
الصينيه كعمله وطنيه لها وليست لديها عمله
وطنيه قام تسليم باعفاء العديد من هذه
الدول من ديونها للصين مقابل ايضا تقديم
او استمرار في التعاطي او استيراد البضائع
الصينيه القوه الصينيه قوه جارفه لا يمكن
ايقافها الا باسلحه نوويه واعتقد ان الغرب
للاسف لن يجلس كما جلس معستالين وقسم
العالم يرفض عمليه تقاسم الاسواق وهي
حقيقه يجب عليهم ان يقروا ان من حق
السعوديه كمنتج لنفط ان تحدد اسعار النفط
ولا تعدد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
حق الامارات ان تجد نفط او غاز او الجزائر
تنتج غاز بقدر احتياجاتها وليس بقدر
احتياجات الغرب ان ترسم هي سياسات
الاقتصاديه والسياسه النفطيه وسياسهم
بعيدا يعني عن العقليه التي تريد ان تحكم
وتقود العالم كما توصف من قبل المعسكر
الاخر بس لو سمحت
التحذيراتك ومن التداعيات المحتمله
للتصعيد الحالي قبل نشوب حرب اذا نشبت
اكبر من كل فتره كورونا واكبر من الحرب
الاوكرانيه
طبعا لانه
الكتف الكتف او محاوله ازاحه الصين بالقوه
عن عن الهرم الاقتصادي الان دخل القومي
للصين اعلم للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هذا يعني انها المرتبه الاولى والقس القوه
الاقتصاديه يعني القوه السياسيه قوه
التاثير السياسي والاقتصادي ونلاحظ ان
هناك تمرد هناك ظهور لاقطاب جديده وما
شابه ذلك قد يكون هناك افكار نيره
لاخواننا بالخليج يظهروا يعني يقوم بانشاء
عمله وطنيه خليجيه وهي القوه خامسه تعتبر
اقتصاديا فاعتقد الغرب خسر والان هو
يستعمل اخر اسلحته ولكن العقليه الغربيه
لن تتردد باستعمال اي شيء مقابل الحفاظ
على حصتها في السوق
قريبا جدا عنده بنك التنميه عم بعينوا له
رئيسه برازيل السابقه رئيسه له ورئيس
البرازيل الالو لدى سيلفا سيحضر ذلك شكرا
جزيلا لك من اثينا عبر سكايب الدكتور عبد
اللطيف درويش الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بج
امعه كارديف متروبوليت تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا التي ورغم برد الشتاء لكن ما
زالت الحرب مشتعله فيها وفيزا تحديدا قصفت
القوات الروسيه مبنى سكانيا اليوم معالم
الحياه اختفت هنا احترق بعضها والبعض
الاخر اصبح ركاما ليسقط في هذا القصف رجل
وابنته البالغه احد عشر عاما ولم يتبقى
الا ذكراها بعد صاروخين من طراز استثلاث
مئه اصابا المدينه ما زاد من الفجوه بين
الروس والاوكران في حرب دخلت عامها الثاني
ولا تزال مستمره
كانت هناك زوجه وزوجها ايفان الاطفال
كانوا صغارا ماتت فتاه في سياره الاسعاف
وتم انقاذ الام لكنها كان من الممكن ان
تحترق حيه كما حدث للاب
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان طائره
سوخويا 34 استهدفت جسرا في الاوكرانيه
وذلك لمنع قوات اوكرانيه تابعه للمخابرات
من التقدم باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه ومنطقه
بريانس كالحدوديه بالتحديد
نشرت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه صوره لمقاتله
من طراز 29 التي ورثتها اوكرانيا عن
الاتحاد السوفيتي وتم تثبيت صاروخ من طراز
هارم الامريكي تحت جناح الطائره وتعد هذه
اول مره يتم فيها دمج اسلحه روسيه مع اخرى
امريكيه منذ بدايه حرب اوكرانيا
في العربيه 360 ايضا وثائق الفانتاجون
المسربه تكشف ان اوكرانيا ستفشل في فرض
دفاع جوي فعال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في كواليس الحرب
الاوكرانيه لم يعد هناك شيء مستغرب وباتت
التطورات
رهن مجريات يوميه لا تستند على خطط واقعيه
وبعيدا عن ميدان المعارك وثائق عسكريه
سريه تسربت من البانتاجون الى العالم
لتحدث جدلا واسعا في اروقه العالم بسبب ما
تحتوي عليه من معلومات وخفايا منها تخص
الحرب الاوكرانيه واخرى تخص كوريا
الجنوبيه
واسرائيل صحيفه بوليتيكو قالت ان الوثائق
كشفت عن وجود قوات من حلف الناتو
باوكرانيا تتبع لفرنسا وامريكا وبريطانيا
اما صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه فذهبت
بعيدا واظهرت مدى عمق اختراق الولايات
المتحده للجيش والاستخبارات في روسيا
التقارير والاستخباراتيه ايضا كشفت ان
واشنطن تتجسس على القاده العسكريين
والسياسيين لاوكرانيا فضلا عن حلفاء
امريكيين مهمين اخرين
اما بخصوص حصه كوريا الجنوبيه من الوثائق
المسربه فهي تتعلق بمناقشات خاصه بين كبار
المسؤولين في كوريا الجنوبيه حول الضغط
الامريكي على بلادهم لامداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه
في المقابل اكد مسؤولون من كوريا الجنوبيه
انسول وبعد علمها بتسريب الوثائق السريه
تعتزم مناقشه واشنطن في القضايا التي
اثارتها التسريبات
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تتبع عورات روسيا
العسكريه لتكشف عيوبها امام الجيش
الاوكراني
البانتاجون يخترق بعمق اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات الروسيه وفق ما جاء في
الوثائق المسربه خطوه جعلت واشنطن قادره
على تحذير اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط
لها وتقديم تقييم لقوه اله الحرب الروسيه
ومنحتها فهما واسعا للتخطيط الروسي
وامكانيه تحذير حلفائها بشان عمليه موسكو
في المستقبل
الوثائق المسربه ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي
المتهاوي الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
بيانات اتاحت لواشنطن نقل المعلومات
الحساسه من اجل الدفاع عن نفسها من خلال
تحديد توقيت الضربات واهدافها بدقه في
حاله يرثى لها هكذا قيم الامريكيون الجيش
الاوكراني وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الوثائق تفصل نقص المخصصه للدفاعات الجويه
لدى الجيش الاوكراني كما تناقش المكاسب
التي تحققها القوه الروسيه حول مدينه
باخموت الشرقيه
القاده السياسيون والعسكريون في اوكرانيا
لم يكونوا بمعزل عن اعين التجسس الامريكي
وفق الوثائق المسربه ايضا
تحليلات قالت ان هذه الوثائق بامكانها
الحاق ضرر حقيقي بالمجهود الحربي
الاوكراني ان استطاعت موسكو قطعه مصادر
المعلومات
البيانات اظهرت ايضا تعمل بنشاط لتهديد
المصالح الامريكيه واحباط مشاريعها في
افريقيا ومناطق اخرى
احدى هذه الوثائق كشفت ان مسؤولين من
فاجنر التقوا سرا بجهات تركيه في فبراير
وبحثوا تهريب اسلحه ومعدات لاستعمالها في
اوكرانيا وفق ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
خبراء قالوا ان الوثائق تبدو صحيحه لكن
ادخل التعديلات على بعضها لعكس صوره افضل
عن الوضع الروسي لاسيما من خلال التقليل
من حجم الخسائر الروسيه بلال البجداني
العربيه
عموما اذا يوسو كيول يونسوكيول الرئيس
الكوري سيبحث موضوع هذه الوثائق المسربه
مع الرئيس الامريكي في زيارته في السادس
والعشرين من ابريل زياره الدوله الى
واشنطن وثائق سريه او هذه الوثائق
العسكريه الامريكيه المسربه كشفت عن ازمه
الذخائر حاده تعاني منها اوكرانيا ما قد
يضعف قدراتها الدفاعيه بحلول الصيف المقبل
نشرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست وثائق سريه مسربه
منسوبه الى المخابرات الامريكيه تتعلق
بتمركز القوات الاوكرانيه ومواقع بطاريات
الدفاع على الجبهه وكنتيجه للاستنزاف
الروسي وعدم مواكبه الامدادات الغربيه
الاحتياجات الجبهه اتجهت اوكرانيا الى
حمايه المواقع الحساسه اضافه لاستهداف
الحوامات والمقاتلات دون اهدار الذخيره
بهدف التصدي للمسيرات وبحسب الارقام التي
وردت في التسريبات ستكون اوكرانيا قد
استنزفت صواريخ الدفاع البعيده المدى وهي
الان تعتمد فقط على الصواريخ القصيره
والمتوسطه المدى وهو ما يهددها بفقدان
السيطره على اجوائها بحلول يونيو المقبل
نقص الدخائر دفع القياده الاوكرانيه
للمطالبه بتسريع الامدادات الغربيه الا ان
تحديثا للقوات الجويه اكد اقتراب استلام
انظمه دفاع غربيه جديده
الوثائق اثارت بلبله في عدد من الدول حول
العالم من بين هذه الدول اسرائيل التي نفت
تقارير حول مشاركه عناصر من جهاز
المخابرات الخارجيه المصاد في التظاهرات
ضد خطه تغيير النظام القضائي ونفت اسرائيل
الامر جمله وتفصيلا
[موسيقى]
وثائق البنتاجون تطال اسرائيل ومظاهراتها
واحتوت معلومات تفيد بتشجيع الموساد
لموظفيه والمواطنين الاسرائيليين على
الاحتجاج ضد الحكومه
بحسب الوثائق دعا كبار مسؤولي الموساد
الاسرائيليين للاحتجاج على خطه تغيير
النظام القضائي التي اقترحتها حكومه
نتنياهو
وثائق البنتاجون قالت ان رئيس جهاز
الموساد سمح لموظفه بالمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات بصفه مدنيه وعلى ان لا يظهر
انتمائهم
وسائل اعلام غربيه وصفت موقف الموساد
بالتمرد السري خاصه وانه جهاز مخابرات
خارجي ممنوع من التدخل في السياسه
رئاسه الحكومه التي يتبع لها جهاز الموساد
اوضحت ان القصه التي اوردتها نيويورك
تايمز واشنطن بوست كاذبه ولا اساس لها على
الاطلاق
الموساد نشر بدوره بيانا نفافيه صحه
التقارير الاعلاميه واكد ان المخابرات لم
تشجع تنظيم مظاهرات ضد الحكومه
[موسيقى]
رغم ان ترامب اتهم ديمقراطيين باستغلال
قضيه شخصيه لاهداف سياسيه الا ان حمله
ترامب لم تفوت مشاهد وقوفها امام القضاء
لاعطاء زخم جديد للمترشح الضحيه الذي
يحتاج المال والاصوات لاصلاح الاوضاع في
البلاد
بعد ان اكتملت اركان الخطه غادرت تومب
منزله في فلوريدا تحت الاضواء
بث مباشر على كل القنوات ومئات الانصار في
الشوارع لتحيته اقامته في نيويورك كانت
محسوبه بالدقيقه اما خطواته المتثاقله
التي قادته الى القاضي فقد كانت جزءا من
بروفه تفاصيلها اعدت مسبقا مصدر من داخل
البيت اكد ان المتهمه ناقشه طويلا مع
دفاعه السلوك الامثل اثناء المحاكمه
تعابير الوجه ولغه الجسد كانت كلها تصب في
اتجاه مشهد واحد الضحيه والجلاد
ايام بعدها جاء دور الاخراج تروم نشر مقطع
فيديو يروي في اقل من دقيقه قصه رئيس سابق
خضع للقانون رغم براءته المسبقه
[موسيقى]
شاهده الملايين وبات واجهه الحمله
الانتخابيه
المترشح يتجه تدريجيا لاستهداف مشاعر سكان
وسط امريكا ضد امبرياليه واشنطن ونيويورك
اما انصاره فقد ازدادوا تشددا خاصه بعد ان
انتصر في قضيه اخرى امام ستورم دانييلز
بعيدا عن نيويورك محكمه كاليفورنيا الزمت
الممثله الاباحيه دفع مبلغ قدره 600 الف
دولار تعويضا عن بطلان ادعاءها بالتعرض
للتهديد
استغل القضيه والطالب بالمزيد من اموال
المتبرعين اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين دولار
جمعت فقط لدعمه امام القضاء لكن العوده
للبيت الابيض مشروع يلتهم المال دون حساب
تحول محاكمه الى دعايه انتخابيه لم يعد
مساله جدليه في امريكا لكن قدره ترامب على
استماله الاصوات المتارجحه تحدي اخر يلزمه
تقمص دور المنقذ لا ضحيه يجر وراءه
المشاكل
[موسيقى]
كشف صحيفه بوليتيكول الامريكيه ان تلويح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمراجعه
علاقاتها مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
العام الماضي بعد قرار انتاج النفط لم
ينفذ ابدا وان التصريحات في حينه كانت
بسبب الحرج الامريكي من قرار
اكتوبر من عام 2022 اوبيك بلس فاجات
العالم بخفض الانتاج بمعدل مليوني برميل
يوميا
امريكا اعلنت معارضتها للخطوه والسعوديه
مضت قدما فيها اتهامات للرياض بالوقوف في
صف بوتين وتهديدات امريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه
وبينما كانت الولايات المتحده تراجع
علاقتها مع السعوديه كما تقول مضت المملكه
في طريق مصالحها الامنيه والاقتصاديه رؤيه
2030 للامير محمد بن سلمان تطلبت استقرارا
سياسيا السعوديه وايران اتفقتا على اعاده
العلاقات بوساطه الصين الرغبه في استقرار
سياسي بالمنطقه يقود الى نماء اقتصادي
وتامين خطوط امداداتها الى العالم
صحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه كشفت انه وبعد
مضي سته اشهر من التصريحات لمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه لم يحدث شيء وان
حديث بايدن عن العواقب كان سببه فقط
الشعور بالحرج من خطوه اوبك بلس الصحيفه
اكدت ان اداره بايدن لا تستطيع الاستغناء
عن السعوديه وانها لم تجري اي مباحثات
جديه لمراجعه العلاقات معتبره ان زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه غير
المعلنه للرياض جاءت في سياق استعاده
العلاقات القويه مع السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بشكل لافت ومكثف اقتحم مئات المستوطنين
اليوم باحات المسجد الاقصى وسط حمايه من
القوات الاسرائيليه التي قيدت وصول
المصلين المسلمين الى المسجد نحو الف من
هؤلاء المستوطنين اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى
في اوسع اقتحام للمسجد بعدما اقتحمت
الشرطه المسجد واخرجت المعتكفين من داخله
بالقوه لتامين وصول المستوطنين الى المكان
هذا الاقتحام ياتي في ذروه توتر كبير في
المنطقه سببته الاقتحامات المتزايده ما
دعا الجيش الاسرائيلي لتمديد الاغلاق
المفرود على الضفه الغربيه ومعابر قطاع
غزه حتى منتصف ليل الاربعاء المقبل وفي
وقت تعيش فيه اسرائيل اوقاتا عصيبه
واحتمال اندلاع مواجهه متعدده الجبهات
اوسط الشرطه الاسرائيليه امس بعدم السماح
للمستوطنين باقتحام المسجد الاقصى خلال
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان في محاوله
لتجنب زياده التوتر وقدمت
التوصيه خلال مناقشات لقاده ورؤساء
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه خشيه
احتكاكات قد تتحول الى مواجهات والى تصعيد
على نطاق اوسع وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تمر بن جزير رفض قبول توصيه
الشرطه الا انه عبر عن اعتقاده بان الجهات
الامنيه ستدعم توصيه الشرطه وستفرض منعا
على وصول اليهود للاقصى لمنع تدهور اكبر
للاوضاع في الجانب السياسي ارجع رئيس
المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايرلابي التوتر
الاوضاع بالمسجد الاقصى الى عدم مسؤوليه
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو كما اتهم لابيد
وزير الامن القومي
بمحاوله اشعال الشرق الاوسط مضيفا ان ما
يحدث حاليا هو المتوقع عندما تكون
المسؤوليه بيد اكثر الرجال تطرفا في
اسرائيل على حد قول لابيد في اشاره الى
بنكير نفسه
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه طلب رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بمصادره
الصلاحيات المتعلقه بالحرم القدسي من اتمر
بنك فير واكد عقب لقاء جمعه بنتنياهو انه
يدعم اي اجراء امني تقدم عليه اسرائيل ردا
على الهجوم الصاروخي الاخير الا انه شدد
على رفض المعارضه قرار اقاله من منصب
وزاره الدفاع وفي وقت لاحق اكد حزبا لكود
ان لابيد اختار ممارسه تافهه في الوقت
الذي تحارب فيه اسرائيل على ثلاث جبهات
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات علشان الطيران الاسرائيلي غارات
على سوريا كشفت اسرائيل عن المواقع التي
قصفتها بالداخل السوري والتي شملت مجمعا
عسكريا لقوات النظام السوري وانظمه رادار
عسكريه فيما اكدت القناه الثالثه عشره
الاسرائيليه ان ضربه امس استهدفت مقرا
تابعا للفرقه الرابعه التابعه لماهر الاسد
[موسيقى]
سلسله غارات شنتها القوات الاسرائيليه على
الاراضي السوريه ردا على اطلاق قذائف
وصاروخيه باتجاه هضبه الجولان المحتله
بينها عده مواقع عسكريه في محيط دمشق
والقنيطره شملت مجمعا عسكريا تابعا للفرقه
الرابعه دون انباء عن اصابات المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكد ان طائراتهم استهدفت
منظومات رادارات فضلا عن موقع لجماعات
مواليه لايران في محيط قريه ابو قاوق
وبلده السعسع بريف دمشق الجنوبي
الاستهدافات شملت كذلك مواقع مدفعيه لقوات
النظام وجماعات ايرانيه بمحيط قريه الكوم
وساريه الصيد الجولان في محافظه القنيطره
وسريه عابدين وسريه معربه الواقعه بحوض
اليرموك بريف درعا ياتي ذلك عقب اطلاق
ثلاث قذائف صاروخيه من سوريا نحو هضبه
الجولان المحتله اثنتان منها وقعتا في
منطقه مفتوحه وقذيفه اخرى اعترضت من
الدفاعات الجويه كما سبق ذلك اطلاق اكثر
من 30 صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
اسرائيل لم تتبنها اي وجهه لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انها نيران فلسطينيه لا
تقفوا ميليشيا حزب الله وراءها
[موسيقى]
وصل وفدان سعودي وعماني الى صنعاء لبحث
جهود احلال السلام وتراس الوفد السعوديه
السفير محمد الجابر الذي التقى صحبه رئيس
الوفد العماني القيادي الحوثي مهدي المشاط
اللقاء سيبحث تمديد الهدنه والعمل على
اجراءات لبناء الثقه واختبار التوصل الى
حل سياسي شامل في اليمن
في العربيه 360 ايضا وزاره الحج والعمره
السعوديه تشدد اجراءات التحقق من تصاريح
الزوار والمعتمرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كثفت وزاره الحج والعمره
السعوديه من جهودها للتاكد من تصاريح
المعتمرين وتاتي هذه الخطوه للحد من
التزاحم والتاكد من الدخول للنظامي للزوار
والمعتمرين للمسجد الحرام مراسل العربيه
افاد بان وزاره الحج والعمره تعمل على
التاكد من تاريخ التصريح ووقت اداء مناسك
العمره وتنظيم الحركه الخاصه بالمعتمرين
[موسيقى]
منا مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه اسامه قاسم
اهلا بك معنا اسامه كيف ينعكس هذا التشديد
على التاكد من تصاريح المعتمرين عندك على
الارض
اهلا وسهلا طاهر تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
المشاهدين العربيه نعم اليوم نحن نتحدث عن
جهود وزاره الحج والعمره في التاكد من
التصاريح لجميع المعتمرين الداخلين الى
صحن المطاف نقف الان مقابل باب الملك عبد
العزيز احد اكبر الابواب المؤديه الى صحن
المطاف اترككم الان عبر الكاميرا العربيه
لنشاهد هذه الجهود من قبل وزاره الحج
والعمره للتاكد من التصاريح طبعا يتاكدون
من تاريخ التصريح ووقت التصريح ويوم
التصريح ما اذا كان التصريح ايضا بنفس
الوقت وبنفس اللحظه وبنفس التوقيت الذي
اتى به المعتمد طبعا رصدت هناك حالات
تجاوز انه ياتي مثلا قبل الموعد او بعد
الموعد او حتى في لحظه لم يصدر فيها
التصحيح وايضا رصدوا عدد من المتجاوزين
الذين لم ياتوا اساسا بتصاريح لدخولهم الى
صحن المطاف طبعا كما اسبقت طاهر هذا اكبر
ابواب الحرم المكي الذي يؤدي الى صحن
المطافه هنا نشاهد عبر الكاميرا العربيه
تاكد من تصاريح المعتمرين الداخلين الى
المطاف من داخل باب الملك عبد العزيز طبعا
نتحدث اليوم طاهر عن اكثر وحوالي 17 مليون
زائر ومعتمر وصلوا الى يومنا هذا الى مكه
المكرمه بالتحديد الى الحرم المكي نشهد
ايضا توافد وجود الكثير من الزوار
والمعتمرين خلال الايام القادمه نتحدث
اليوم ايضا عن استكمال الخطه التشغيليه
الثانيه التي ما زالت ما زال بها تقريبا
يومان ثم انطلاق الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه
وهي خطه تشغيليه للعشر اواخر تحدثنا اليوم
ايضا ان التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه تم
افتتاح جميع ادوارها الخمسه اضافه الى
السطح ولاول مره يتم فتح سطح التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه لاستقبال عدد اكبر من
المصلين طبعا التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
تستقبل حوالي مليون مصلي في الساعه ونتحدث
ايضا الان من هذه المنطقه المركزيه للحرم
المكي ونشاهد التزاحم ووفود الزوار
والمعتمرين القادمين من باب اجياد ومن
العزيزيه كذلك ومن عدد من مداخل الحرم
نشهد ايضا وجودهم اليوم ودخولهم الى صحن
المطاف من خلال باب الملك عبد العزيز الذي
نشير ايضا بان رجال الحج والعمره متواجدين
في اكثر من بوابه رصدنا هذه البوابه ايضا
جهود كبيره جدا يقوم بها رجال الحج
والعمره هذه الوزاره تقدم الكثير اليوم
السعوديه ايضا اقدمت الدعم لجميع الزوار
والمعتمرين لينعموا بهذه التجربه وليعيشوا
تجربه مثاليه اثناء وصولهم الى المسجد
الحرام طبعا نحن نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
الكثير من الخدمات التي تقدم للزوار
والمعتمرين بمناسبه ايضا دخول العشر
الاواخر بعد يومين من خلال ايضا تقديم عدد
الاشتراك اكبر من سقيا زمزم وايضا تجهيز
المفارش وتعطيرها وتنظيفها وتعقيم ايضا
المداخل والمخارج هناك قوه كبيره جدا على
مستوى العمال والمهندسين والمنفذين
ليقدموا كل هذه الخدمات للزائر والمعتمر
نعيش الى اليوم كل هذه الايام وفق خطه
ممنهجه وفق خطه تمشي على ما يرام وتمضي
ايضا بخطى مستقيمه لنشهد ايضا هذا النجاح
الكبير وعدم وجود مثلا حالات استصعب
الوصول اليها او حتى حالات حرجه متواجده
مثلا داخل المسجد الحرام او حتى في ساحات
المسجد الحرام ان شاء الله دائما
هو اذا سمحت لي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا
الشرح الوافي اسامه قاسم مراسل العربيه من
مكه المكرمه تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في عالم الدراما الخليجيه
ظهر الفنان الكبير ناصر القصبي مرتديا
السوداني ومستخدما العاميه السودانيه
ليكسب قلوب الشعب السوداني حيث اشتهر
بشخصيه سودانيه فريده عاكس من خلالها
تعامل واخلاق السودانيين والقضايا التي
تهمهم في طاش العوده كما فاجا الجمهور
باسماء ومعالم ومفردات موغله في العاميه
السودانيه
[موسيقى]
في الماده 82 قال بتسمح
كانت وما زالت الشخصيه السودانيه حاضره في
اجزاء سلسله الطاش اجاده النجم نصر القصبي
للعاميه السودانيه جعلت شخصيه الزول عثمان
التي يؤديها من الاقرب لقلوب السودانيين
مدبره منزليه ناصر قدم الشخصيه بشكل كويس
ودي الشخصيه اللي نحن قاعدين نشوفها مثلا
في روايات الطيب صالح وقاعدين نشوفها في
في الشخصيات السودانيه المتقدمه يعني نحن
شفنا الانسان السوداني هو كبير اخصائيين
وشفناه وهو مهندس كبير جدا وشفناه ومحاسب
وداء ارجع لامانتو لصدقه اتمنى اشوف شخصيه
ناصر القصبي في واحد من السماسره اللي
يجيدوا البيع والشراء لانه عنده حنكه
في الكلام جميله جدا
زين تقليدي يتميز به انسان شرقي السودان
ويعرف بالسديري اما الجلابيه فهي زي قومي
كما العمامه يرتديها الرجل السوداني في
مختلف المناسبات ناصر القصبي او الزرع
عثمان اصبح حديث شارع السوداني تعالوا مع
بعض نشوف اراء شارع
حفرجك على واحد من مراجعه
لانك
القرش ما بيطلع منك يا سلام كل يعني
المتفاجاه واكيد الشعب السوداني كلهم
متفيق زي كده انه نحن عندنا شخصيات كثيره
او عند جنسيات كتيره في السودان اجانب ما
بيطغرل ولا كلمه يعني زي ما هو اجاد
اللهجه حقتنا السودانيه دخل قلوبنا
باللهجه السودانيه اللي بيقدمها لنا كل
سنه وبعدين نظره في حاجه في الموسم ده لما
قاعد يقول لنا
حرمت حرم
ة ضحكت اكثر كلمه ضحكتني لما قالت تعرفت
على وحده الفيسبوك حبيته وحنتزوج وحطينا
قرص
يعني حرفيا انا حسيت بس ده ده
بيجسد الشخصيه السودانيه صح لانه يعني
الشخصيه السودانيه صعبه
العوده تفاعلا كبيرا نتابع بعض ردود
الافعال
العزاب شنو انتم
لا والله
ماما شافت وعد
وعدس تجننين كده
اسكت
والله والله
ابوي كان النكته هنا دقيقه زياده
[موسيقى]
سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من النمسا
وتحديدا من بحيره زيكسي التي جفت بالفعل
تغيرات المناخ لكن ظهرت نباتات جديده من
البحيره الجافه وكان الارض تعطينا درسا
لانه رغم قسوه البشر على الطبيعه الا ان
الحياه تشق طريقها حتى من الصخر لتعطي
املا جديدا
فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360 في الاقصى كل
يولي قبلته فبين من خر ساجدا امنا مطمئنا
قبلته المسجد الحرام وبين من جعل قبله
بندقيته المصلين سقط العدل على المداخل
فدخلوا الى الاقصى ليستوطن التوتر ساحاته
لكن يكفيك ان تعرف صاحب الارض من قبلته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات